we're in the last section of test 6.
section 9 page 743
problem number one
problem number one for which of the
following values of m will the value of
3m minus 1 be greater than 10. so three
m
minus one and they say for what values
of m will be greater than ten so we add
one to both sides
three m
is going to be greater than eleven
divide both sides by three and you don't
have to switch the inequality because 3
is positive so you get m
is going to be greater than 11 over 3.
right 11 over 3 this is what this is
equal to 3 and 2 3. so anything greater
than 3 really any integer greater than
3. if you'll get all the choices the
only one that's greater than three and
two-thirds
is choice a four
next problem
if a times k is equal to k
sorry if a
times k is equal to a for all values of
a
for all values of a
what is the value of k and the reason
why they have to say all values of a is
because if a was 0 then that would work
for any k
but if it's for all values of k divide
both sides of this equation by a you get
k is equal to a over a
right which is equal to 1.
so k would have to be equal 1 which is d
and you knew that you didn't have to do
any algebra if i multiply
something times some number and i get
the original thing that number is going
to be one
problem three
image
okay so let me draw
what they've drawn so one parallel line
like that
i'm assuming they're parallel because
they look parallel in the picture
and then
there's a line that comes down like this
there's another line that goes up like
that
what do they tell us about it
they tell us that this is x degrees
right here
this is z degrees
this is y degrees this is line l this is
line m
in the figure above l is parallel to m
right l is parallel to m
if x is equal to 80 degrees so this is
80 degrees
x is equal to 80 degrees and y is equal
to 70 degrees
y is equal to 70 degrees
what is the value of z
so the trick here is just to see the
opposite angles and that in fact the
information that there are parallel
lines is actually just extra information
to start making you do you know
corresponding angles and all that kind
of fancy stuff which you could do but
the really easy thing is to realize that
x this angle is the same thing as this
angle which is going to be 80 degrees
right because they're opposite angles of
intersecting lines
and this if that's 70 then this angle is
also going to be 70.
and now 80 plus 70 plus z has to add to
180 because they're all in the same
triangle together
right so 80
plus 70
plus z is equal to 180
150 plus z is equal to 180
subtract 150 from both sides you get z
is equal to 30 degrees
the other way you could have done it is
you could have said the court you could
have used the information about the
parallel lines and you could have said
well the corresponding angle here is
here so that this is also 80 degrees and
you could have said the corresponding
angle here is also here so this is 70
degrees
and then you can set all three of these
are supplementary and that they would
have to add up to 180 and that you would
get z equals 30 either way and that is
choice a
next problem
problem four
the scenic route from me is home to her
office is five kilometers longer than
the direct route so i'll call s for
scenic
s
is equal to the direct route plus four
right it's the the scenic route is four
miles longer than the direct route or
four kilometers
when she goes by the scenic route and
returns by the direct route the round
trip is 35 kilometers so that means what
the distance of the scenic route
plus
the distance of the direct route is
equal to 35 kilometers right because
they're saying the whole trip the scenic
route plus the direction is 35
kilometers
how many kilometers is the direct route
so we want to solve for this
right so this top equation we can we can
rewrite this
as
we could rewrite this as
s
minus d
is equal to 4.
right
and actually just to make things well
let me write that down right here so you
get s
minus d
is equal to 4.
and you we can multiply this equation by
negative 1 so you cancel out the s
instead of the d's but since it's so
convenient already let's just cancel out
the d's and solve for the scenic route
the s's
so let's this is just a
system of two equations two unknowns so
let's add these two equations so you get
2s
d plus d is 0
is equal to
35 plus 4.
35 plus 4 is 39
right the numbers look strange so the
scenic distance is
over two
right that's 39 over two kilometers and
what does that equal to if i were to
write that as a mixed number let's see
38 is that's 19
and one half kilometers
19 and one half kilometers right a
little less than 20 kilometers that's
the scenic route
the direct route is 4 less than that
right we said the scenic route is 4 more
than the direct route so the direct
route is going to be that minus 4. so
what's 19 minus 4. it's 15 and then you
still have that half there so it's 15
and a half kilometers
and i don't see that choice there so i
must have made a mistake let me let me
actually let me let me do it here just
to see where i
i don't see that choice the scenic route
from mia's home to her office is five
kilometers longer than the direct round
right
the scenic route we could even say
scenic route minus
oh sorry it's five kilometers longer
sorry see this is five that was my
mistake
five kilometers longer scenic minus
direct light is five right they normally
don't give weird numbers like that so
this is five
this is forty
this is forty over two
this is 20 hope i'm not confusing you
and then if you're going to be 5 less
than 20 it's going to be 15 kilometers
right
hope you see what i just did i mean i
just made i wrote four kilometers long
instead of five that was my mistake
which you should avoid all right next
problem
let me switch colors i think that that
yellow induces careless mistakes
five
a complete cycle of a traffic light
takes 80 seconds
during each cycle the light is green for
40 seconds so green
40 seconds
amber i guess that's red
amber
for 10 seconds
oh i guess amber is yellow i don't know
my colors and red for 30 seconds
and red for 30 seconds right and the
whole cycle takes 80 seconds right if
you add those up
at a randomly chosen time what is the
probability that the light will not be
red
so the probability that the light will
not be red is the probability
that it's going to be green or amber
and it's greener amber for 40 plus 10
for
50 seconds
out of a total of 80 seconds right so
the probability that when you randomly
you know walk up to the light that it's
going to be green or amber or not red is
going to be 50 seconds
50 over 80
which is 5 over 8
and that is choice b
next problem
problem six
for a certain hot water heater the
increase in heating expenses is directly
proportional to the increase in the
water temperature setting
if heating expenses increase by twenty
four dollars
when the
when the water temperature is increased
by 20 degrees fahrenheit so
expense
expense goes up by
when temperature
when temperature is increased by 20
degrees
right
fahrenheit
by how much will heating expenses
increase when the water temperature
setting is increased by 15 degrees
fahrenheit so this is just a ratio
problem so you say well the expenses go
up 24 degrees 24
when we have a 20 degree increase
in temperature so then how many dollars
will it increase
when you have a 15 degree increase right
this is the denominator in both cases
was the change in temperature and then
this is the change in expense the
triangle means change right so you just
have to make sure that the ratios are
consistent and let's just multiply you
get 20.
actually and so we
don't have to get big numbers let me
reduce this fraction this is divide the
top and the bottom this is the same
thing as 6
over 5 is equal to x over 15. this is
easier to multiply now you get 5x
is equal to 15 times 6. divide both
sides by 5. you get x is equal to 15
times six divided by five
that's three that's one that's eighteen
so the change in expense will be
eighteen dollars and that's choice b
see in the next video